Welcome to the Sequencer Modular Framework for Game Development
course for Unreal Engine 5.5.
This course is the third video in this series designed
to provide knowledge in Sequencer-based workflows,
specifically building in-game cutscenes for video games.
We'll recap game development principles, Sequencer concepts,
features, and tools of Sequencer,
then dive into migrating level-based logic
into a standalone Blueprint to control in-game cutscenes.
Finally, we'll cover some best practice recommendations
when using Sequencer for game development.
For this course, you'll find the Sequence 305 Start Map located
in the Content, Courses, Sequence 305.0.0 Maps folder.
Let's get started.